in 2007 the Big Bang Theory debuted on
CBS
but the sitcom didn't explode in
popularity until reruns hit syndication
since then it's season premieres have
routinely ranked near the top of network
TV ratings and reruns dominate the list
of most watched cable shows
but furnace huge there are bound to be
some big bangs behind the scenes - the
pilot reconceptualization the show
that's aired for nearly a decade is very
different from the original pilot Jim
Parsons as Sheldon was originally a
horndog his character was changed to
someone mystified by romance I've seen
six women naked some of them weren't
even relatives
kaley cuoco z-- penny was also absent
instead the attractive neighbor was the
unfriendly Katey played by Amanda Walsh
Johnny Galecki as Leonard wore suits
instead of hoodies and there was one
other change the theme song was Thomas
Dolby's she blinded me with science
cBS past but as creators Chuck Lorre and
Bill Prady to rework the show and submit
another pilot they did adding an
original theme by barenaked ladies and
made it to air in 2007 the Bernadette
vocalisation Bernadette's mousy
high-pitched voice and loud moments of
screaming rage don't come naturally to
actress melissa rauch although she
doesn't sound like Bernadette in real
life rausch took her inspiration from
the source close to home her own mother
don't say things like I went to the
grocery store and I had to return
something they sent me to three
different town is it was a real circle
jerk
the paycheck extortion in 2014
production of the show's eighth season
was delayed due to contract
renegotiations between the cast and
Warner Brothers ultimately CBS renewed
the show for an unprecedented three
seasons keeping it on the air through
2017 Jim Parsons Johnny Galecki and
Kaley Cuoco each secured a salary of
$1,000,000 per episode meanwhile Simon
Helberg and Kunal Nayyar renegotiated
their new contracts collectively ending
up with salaries of around 750 thousand
dollars per episode a settlement was
reached the day before their old
contracts expired but the duo would have
reportedly been written out of the show
if they hadn't accepted the deal the
relationship obfuscation kaley cuoco has
often appeared in tabloids due to her
brief marriage to tennis player Ryan
Sweeting still she avoided the spotlight
during her previous relationship even
though it was with a noteworthy co-star
Wilco and Johnny Galecki dated from 2007
to 2009 and kept it a secret from not
only the media but from the BIGBANG cast
and crew totally felt for each other and
just really wanted to keep it as close
to ourselves possibly had an amazing
relationship the Mayim Bialik
manifestation in the 2008 episode the
bat jar conjecture Sheldon quits the
group's physics ball team raw James high
in the suggestion for a replacement you
know is apparently very smart is the
goal of a TVs blossom she's got a PhD in
neuroscience or something Raj
we're not giving TVs blossom to join our
physics Bowl team and the actress is
Mayim Bialik who later joined the cast
is Amy Farrah Fowler also under
consideration for the role was accuracy
musician Kate Micucci
she was edged out for the part a
producers liked her so much that they
wrote her in anyhow as Lucia the
extremely introverted woman Raj briefly
dates the soft Kitty misappropriation
are you coming co-creator bill Brady
says he heard Sheldon's special calm
down song at his daughter's preschool
assuming it was public domain he added
it to the show where it's been used
multiple times and on BIGBANG
merchandise in 2015 however the family
of a teacher named Edith Nuland sued CBS
allegedly the show lifted lyrics from
new ones 1937 song warm kitty the main
difference
the original 1937 lyrics switched the
first two lines from the song we now
know and love this whole thing could
make for one rich Kitty happy kitty
sleepy kitty thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know what you've heard about the Big
Bang Theory